c'est un paradoxe économique causée par
la crise sanitaire du coc vide 19 le
prix des carburants à la baisse mais une
station-service déserte confiné et
limitées dans leurs déplacements les
citoyens utilisent de moins en moins
leur véhicule
hier matin j'avais assez de monde dans
l'après-midi à des personnes qui
venaient parce que les gens étaient
confinés chez eux
aujourd'hui des psaumes ape que quatre
clients qui sont passés la station parmi
ses clients ce couple dit ni mon teint
sortie avec l'autorisation de
déplacement dérogatoire pour des raisons
médicales
je me suis tant besoin et comment on a
besoin de se déplacer pour des raisons
médicales mais on est obligé d'avoir du
carburant on le fait que le prix shaw
bassée
c'est une bonne nouvelle mais bon je
pense que toute façon on a besoin de
carburant des conditions de travail
adaptées aux salariés de cette station
service gels hydroalcooliques et gants
de protection les précautions sont
prises pour se protéger ça change
beaucoup parce que les clients n'auront
pas dans la boutique pour acheter quand
ils deviendront des mets un peu à
l'écart derrière boutique pour qu'on
puisse avoir des échanges
la seule chose qui change ce qu'il voit
pas pourquoi si dans la boutique avec
des fournisseurs ils viennent y dépose
decroly des eaux et m le bon de commande
ici on prend une fois qu'ils sont partis
auront que le choléra dans la boutique
pour le moment la station service est
ouverte aux horaires habituels
avec le ralentissement de l'activité le
temps de travail des employés pourraient
être réduits durant cette période
exceptionnelle